tonight so please forgive me if I can't
take all the questions just because the
size of the agenda but I will try and
take as many as possible through the
course of the evening
um first agenda item is the tenses so we
know the attendances including officers
and I know that we've had apologies from
councilor James Wright and also
councilor Adele new have we got any
other apologies people are aware of
I'll take that as no
um second is decorations of interest
um are there any Declarations of
Interest anyone would like to uh make me
aware of
no this is going well so far so we'll go
on to agenda item number three and I am
aware that there are two questions have
been uh put forward by members of the
public today the first one was received
from Andrew Gould who cannot be here
tonight but has asked me to ask his
questions so that is what I will do now
so
his question is the friends of
trafford's parks and green spaces a
group representing friends groups across
Trafford would like to question the
recommendation to proceed with the
tennis investment program option C and
Outsource trafford's tennis facilities
to the lawn tennis Association
the friends groups associated with the
individual Parks identified for
inclusion in the program had been
contacted for their opinions we
understand that almost all the groups
were against the proposal to select
option C as it stands
we do have real concerns that any
consultation carried out up until now
has not reached the key stakeholders I.E
those who would most often used
trafford's tennis courts in a formal or
casual way
we offered to help the program to gather
opinions from trafford's tennis players
via our social media and other avenues
and thus helped guide the executive
decision this offer was not taken up we
strongly believe that option C should
not be selected without much wider
consultation with the users of
trafford's tennis spaces
can we ask that this change to tennis
provision in Trafford is extensively
consulted on before a decision is made
so that was Andrew Gould's as a
Committee Member of friends of
trafford's parks and green spaces that
was his question
um I'm now going to pass over to
councilor Joanne Harding thank you
thanks chair and um I welcome this
question and as we go through the agenda
there is a report that I will bring
about the tennis investment project in
which we'll go into more detail
um about some of the points that have
been raised specifically in the question
the outcome of the tennis investment
project is to ensure that our parks and
tennis courts are secured for future use
there is no transfer of ownership
proposed as part of this tennis
investment project the law and Tennis
Association are offering funding to
Trafford Council to improve tennis
facilities in Trafford this funding has
a number of conditions which include the
installation of access gates a
sustainable operating model secured free
provision and the development of a
secure sinking fund these elements have
been shown to increase usage maintenance
and sustainability in similar projects
the feedback of the meetings held with
friends of groups has been shared with
me of those only two have expressed
their outright opposition to all
elements of The Proposal the council
will engage in a full consultation on
this project in the next phase as part
of the briefing offered to friends of
groups the phasing of the project was
set out which indicated that
consultation would happen and was a key
part of the project wants approval to
consult has been obtained we would
welcome support from stakeholders to
promote engagement in this process thank
you chair
thank you councilor Harding I now move
on to the next question I'm delighted to
say that uh Hannah Spencer has joined us
this evening to ask her questions if
you'd like to come up to the table
Hannah and um when you're ready
introduce yourself and ask your
questions thank you
um let me speak today
um so I have a few questions
um I know you may not be able to get
through them all
um but the first one is why I haven't
local groups including friends groups
been properly consulted on the proposed
charge and as far as I understand it
more information has been sought but not
provided
foreign
thank you for your question Hannah and
as I said in the previous response all
parks have been engaged with whether
they choose to engage is an entirely
different matter but actually all parks
have been engaged with during this
process they've all had information
provided to them on the proposals that
will be discussed in more detail later
and their views have been fed back a
full public consultation on charging
will be undertaken in the next phase of
the project and Friends of groups will
continue to be engaged as we discuss
different phases of the project
thank you the next question I have is
will it be free to use at weekends so as
I think I made a point earlier on that
the LTA as part of their funding
proposal will require the council to
make sure there are some free tennis
provision at weekends and the council
will also be seeking to expand its
tennis for free program which didn't
um start back up again post covered we
used to offer some of the tennis free
schemes we're going to provide Outreach
via the operator which is likely to be
free or very heavily subsidized we want
to make tennis inclusive and accessible
for all
thank you and then my next question is
in relation to Stamford part what will
happen to the other activities that are
within the courts already as it's used
for basketball and there's Junior
layouts in that Court as well
so the funding provided is specifically
to safeguard tennis courts because
that's what tennis courts are there for
to provide tennis so it's about in this
instance the courts will be segregated
from other activities so that they
remain accessible for tennis
thank you and then my next question is
is this allowed within the conditions of
the park being left for the public
including the public now needing to pay
to play sports yes it is thank you and
then the next question I only have two
more
um what implications will this have in
relation to Stanford part being grade 2
listed have the appropriate listing
buddies been consulted
the proposed scheme does not have any
impact on the Park's listed status okay
thank you and lastly does this now mean
an end to free tennis for the general
public locations across Trafford
including Stanford park I think as in my
previous response to you Hannah whilst
free access will be reduced and the
council is to see is seeking to develop
a program of use for each site which
maintains some free access at the sites
the actual amount is going to depend on
the site and the number of Courts
the LCA as part of their funding
proposal will require the council as
I've stated to provide some free use at
weekends and we're looking to expand
that tennis for free program and that
will be developed as part of the
Outreach and operator so it's likely to
be free or heavily subsidized
thank you very much
thank you councilor Harding and thank
you Hannah for coming along today to ask
those questions obviously we'll be
discussing that further it's a gender
item 13. so thank you now moving on to
item three sorry item four the minutes
from gosh this sounds feels like a long
long time over to 12th of October and
the 24th of October 2022. I'm happy to
move the mother seconded
seconded thank you
yes
sorry can you put your microphone on
councilor but there was a question that
I asked regarding the modern slavery
statement that was uh discussed
um
and whether it would be part of the taxi
statement of policy as well whether it
was going to be included in that I was
supposed to get a response from the exec
member Council Harding on this uh she
said to get back to me but I'm not as
far as I know received any response so
I'm just wondering whether there's a
response to that please
I'll pick that up um counselor and get
back after the meeting
thank you
okay so we're happy and we've moved
those minutes thank you okay the next
item is the Matters from Council or
overview in scrutiny now we do have an
item here so I'm going to uh pass over
to the chair of scrutiny councilor David
Acton to introduce the budget scrutiny
report councilor Acton
thank you chairman
um
as you'll see uh the the budget scrutiny
reported before us tonight uh I'm not
going to go it go through it word by
word otherwise it'll be here all night
but
um
what what I wouldn't would want to say
is that
um right at the beginning that it's
recognized it was recognized by scrutiny
that Trafford like many other councils
across the UK are operating in very
uncertain and challenging times clearly
this uncertainty creates difficulties in
setting budgets
particularly the cost of living crisis
and inflation is exercising all our
minds and having an adverse impact on
our residents and concerns about that
were mentioned on several occasions by
scrutiny members
uh We've set out 12 recommendations and
you'll you'll see that the second
recommendation mentions and I'll read it
that a report on the expected impact of
the cost of living crisis on residence
and the Council budget including details
of the mitigating steps that the council
is taking
um and that should be submitted to the
scrutiny committee at the first meeting
of the new Municipal year
and I think that that report will be
really important
um
on how we actually deal with that cost
of living
um and all the people that are suffering
um you know financially
um with with that burden and so that I
think will will be an important report
and I think we will need to be monitored
throughout the year by all the
Committees I would all the screws in
committed
um the other recommendations are so
self-explanatory and as we as you will
see scrutiny are suggesting those
Stables saving proposals from different
Services should be monitored very
closely by scrutiny and the executive
throughout the year to ensure the
savings are delivered in in a way that
um you know will
um deliver on
a budget that
um is
good for for the people of Trafford
um but it has to be a budget that is
financially sensible
and finally I'd just like to thank the
executive members and the chief officers
who cooperated so well in the scrutiny
meetings and I think a special thank you
goes to councilor Ross as the chair of
finance and Graham Bentley who is the
director of finance and I think all the
finance officers have done an absolutely
brilliant job and I'd also like to thank
the members of scrutiny who helped to
produce the report
thank you very much councilor Acton
obviously this is a report from scrutiny
to the executive and we will respond as
we do in due course
um you've heard my observations of the
previous scrutiny committee how grateful
I am for this report it's very
constructive it's very realistic and it
obviously sets out the independent
security has from the executive so thank
you very much for that unless there are
any other comments from the executive
I'm going to move on oh yes cuts are
acting I just have one more item
um and it's around the
um the fields of trust uh many of you
will recall the council
referred a motion at a meeting last year
council meeting last year which asks
scrutiny to look into the possibility of
placing all our parks and Open Spaces
um placed into a field of trust
protection in light of that scrutiny
received a report and discussed the
issues and concluded it would be very
expensive for the council as we would
need to employ more staff in the
existing team
um to to actually Implement all of the
156 sites that we have in the borough
and what what I would say is that there
are
um
various protections already on these
sites and some of the sites have field
of trust
protection and some are in the pipeline
to to do that so in light of that
scrutiny committee felt there wasn't a
need to change our existing policy
regarding the protection of our parts
and land I think there there are that
those protect other protections to that
London and the parks that we have and
the cost I think is probably prohibited
so that's a recommendation of the of the
committee
thank you very much for that and thank
you to your scrutiny colleagues for that
work that they've undertaken
okay thank you councilor Acton if we
move on now to agenda item six which is
parking enforcement contract award this
is part one there's a part two to this
I'm gonna sorry yes
apologies Joe I did have a quick
question for a councilor Acton if it was
possible but right I mean it is it was a
report from scrutiny to us but obviously
cancer actions around at the end of the
meeting if you want to ask them sorry so
yes parking enforcement contract Awards
this is part one to councilor Liz Patel
thank you thank you
um
current our current contract for parking
enforcement Services cash collection pay
and display maintenance expires at the
end of March we have undertaken a joint
procurement process with Salford in
times side as they're in a similar
position with their contract time scales
noting we are
procuring a separate contract for
Trafford this report sets out the
procurement process and seeks approval
for awarding this contract to the
winning bidder for a 10-year period with
extension options available in place
after five years part two of this paper
provides more detail on the procurement
assessment and I'm wondering leader if
we wait for that until we offer our
approval
thank you I'm I'm happy to wait for that
in the meantime with the part one
element are there any questions from
executive colleagues
now are there any wider questions at
part one yes councilor but
thank you Joe just a quick question to
find out you know whether with the new
um
tender it we won't be concerned about
the if the the dispute resolution side
of things you know we don't have a
situation where we've got lots of uh
people who
cannot get any kind of resolution or it
takes a long time so we need to have
something in place that is going to be
sort of reasonably affecting allowing
people to be able to
um
challenge things that you know that
happen on that
okay councilor Patel thank you
um I'd have to get back to you on that
counselor but I'm not sure whether the
dispute resolution element falls under
this
um it's it's
we're able through this contract the
reprocurement of this project to to
maintain the current offer that we have
already
um without any Cuts or changes to
services within the available budgets
Richard you have anything on dispute
resolution
in general the PO the appeals process is
set in line we started to requirements
but that's managed by the councils
parking services team rather than
through
um this contract this contract is the
delivery of the Civil enforcement
officers
thank you for that Richard councilor
Welton did you indicate uh yes thank you
leader um just quickly um will the
existing civil Enforcement Officers be
retained
um and also
um it says uh future proof the the um
New services will future-proof Services
reviewing technology and offering
smarter ways of deployment and ticketing
in the future just wondering if there's
any um more details about about what
they're planning what these uh what
these this wonderful new Smart
Technologies might be thank you thank
you there are no Staffing implications
and
the um the electronic options I think
there's a bit of a more information in
part two of that
thank you councilor Patel so we will
note this item in part one and make a
decision in part two uh if people are
happy with that I'm now going to move on
to agenda item seven which is the Civic
quarter action plan and councilor Patel
again
thank you very pleased to present this
report to Executive today it marks a
keyed stage in the final adoption of the
Civic air Civic quarter area action plan
this plan demonstrates that Trafford
Council recognizes and values the
importance of strategic planning by
acting to guide and shape development in
areas of our Borough that contain key
assets and are experiencing change and
are the subject of developer interest
typically in strategic planning this
process has taken some years to conclude
and has been subject to several reports
to exec and a statutory examination
phase there is a wealth of supporting
information here as the formal adoption
of planning policy This Is Not Unusual
it will be a working planning document
that will form the determination of
future planning applications
the plan presents a long-term vision for
a key area which will bring which we
will bring forward in partnership with
landowners developers and infrastructure
providers
the Civic quarter is very close links to
Manchester City Center and Salford keys
and there's an area that sees High
numbers of visitors including those to
Lancashire Cricket Club
it's home to existing communities and
has a number of Key Community facilities
including this town hall Trafford
College UA 92 Stratford police station
and Stratford Leisure Center the plan
provides a coherent flexible long-term
Guide to the area's future development
the report and Associated appendices set
out in Fuller policies from which I
wanted to draw out some key headlines
the plan seeks to create new
neighborhoods with their own distinct
identity enhance Heritage assets support
visitor activity improving green
infrastructure and promoting sustainable
modes of Transport the plan will see the
transformation of 20 hectares of
Brownfield land alongside the delivery
of green spaces we hope to see up to 4
000 new high quality homes
we have the potential for 50 000 square
meters of new office and commercial
space with Associated employment
we're looking to develop a processional
and well-being route which will make the
Trafford a fantastic visitor destination
and help travel and travel to Stratford
Mall connections to surrounding areas
critically this plan will provide a
mechanism to raise and coordinate
developer contributions that can be can
use to support future Community
infrastructure
the Civic quarter area action plan is
the first of several key strategic
planning documents to come forward we
will see the traffic design guide and Co
come forward this year the public
examination of places for everyone is
progressing positively and the adoption
hopeful adoption of places for everyone
will support our local plan to come
forward
finally I'd like to offer a huge thank
you to Residents and businesses and
developers that have taken part in this
process and a particular thanks to
officers who have put a tremendous
amount of work in this over several
years I've seen through this process how
dedicated our offices are to Trafford
and how driven they are by a genuine
desire to make this Borough a better
place thank you
thank you councilor Patel obviously
really good news for the borough this
this item and thank you for all your
hard work on it are there any questions
from the executive
are there any questions from wider
members councilor but
thank you uh I just wanted to make
comment actually that this uh
particularly pleased to see that the
inspectors reviewing the uh this plan uh
sold fit to be able to make the point
that they wanted to see its support for
the growth of Lancashire Cricket Club as
an international soft sporting venue and
tourist attract action which seemed to
have been missed out of the thing and it
came up in the modification 24 as its
reference I mean I know uh your group
has always not been very supportive of
the luxury Club because they've
considered it as a private members Club
but it was our support that we put in or
supported the facilitated 25 million for
this development into a test ground okay
this isn't relevant to the item because
I was like no counselor no I'm just
trying to no no more okay you've made
your points this isn't a critical are
there any other questions I'm glad to
see that it's in the report now that's
been included well that's lovely thank
you are there any other questions from
other members
okay well the recommendations are set
out on the front of the port report all
those in favor
thank you
okay the next item then is moving
traffic offenses and I'm going to pass
to councilor Steve adsed
thank you uh
as you will be aware it has been this is
administration's intention to apply for
enforcement powers under movement
traffic offenses when these become
available to us
and how this is carried out has to be
carried out is set out in the report
before you section one of the report
sets out the background for this
including the legislation that was set
before Parliament last year and the
current timeline for the second
challenge of applications which is
deadline of 15th of February next month
that select section two highlights the
extent to which these Powers apply and
section three sets out the timeline but
for implementation that we as a book
will actually be working to as you will
know part of this work the report sets
out the reasoning and justification
behind the work and details how we are
required to justify each of the
locations proposed and how these fit in
with the aims of the legislation the
trial sites proposed are set out in the
port these sites have been selected as
many of you will personally be aware of
for the locations of non-traffic
hotspots with box auctions are often
getting blocked and causing frustration
and traffic delays for other drivers
underpinning this work is a public
consultation that is required to be
carried out as part of the proposals and
this was held in December and as you
will note from the report something like
57 of the people who engaged in this and
supported it
the
comprehensive information around the
consultation is set out in Section 8 of
the report that I trust you will find
helpful quickly moving on to sections
nine and ten of the report these
proposals are simply the updating of
existing powers from parking enforcement
allow for penalties Etc to be sent
through the post given the agenda share
I'll leave that there and I'll wait any
questions
thank you very much the councilor ad
said and I I note that there's some uh
dependent on funding that comes from
through in the future things like School
streets we could look at with this money
which I think is very welcome news are
there any questions from executive
colleagues yes councilor Slater
it's really important that we we um
support this this evening because
um I don't know how many of you get
contacted around box Junctions and and
people going through traffic lights and
causing hazards so I think that it's
going to be an improvement for our
residents in Trafford and I welcome it
and thank you uh councilor I've had it
and staff who've been working on it
thank you thank you
are there any wider questions I'll go to
councilor for us first
thank you leader
um there are many things to welcome in
this but I'm quite concerned by the
principle of what strikes me as some of
the more illiberal power grabs contained
in parts of this report so in particular
paragraph 5.4 which says additional
enforcement sites can be added without
further consultation I just would like
to hear what the executive feel about
the lack of democratic oversight there
elected members bring local knowledge
provided we're given the opportunity to
share it thank you Council councilor ad
said
thank you a leader because it just set
out in the report further that uh yes
there will be further traunches of this
once the trials have been done however
and that is delegated to a seen a lot in
a sales but however that they will still
have to be consultations in that sense
with local members actually how they
would actually work so there's nothing
will be done on hand here and they'll
obviously as you look at the details
there are set in section six there are a
lot of things to actually that need
enforcing round there actually a problem
out there on the street so I don't see
that this is power grabbing if you want
to put it it's actually helping road
safety and actually keeping traffic
flows one of the biggest frustrations
for drivers particularly is along queues
and they're seeing things like box songs
and other Loops that are completely
blocked up and they can't get through
I've been there myself where you sat
there and like and you can't do anything
you simply can't get there because of it
I think these Powers uh it's been a long
aspiration of this Council to do this
and I think it's certainly something
that we said we would do but when we've
got the powers and we're applying for
those Powers now and that's not these
type of traffic that actually help with
all things you see in the report things
like School streets which I'm sure we'll
support I'm sure you would support in
that Center it and indeed it's a oven
like keep helping enforce to keep School
keep markings clear which at the moment
are relied upon by simply the water
Enforcement Officers using these sort of
facilities we could put a camera on site
to do that in addition we could also
look further down the road at things
like look people are abusing one-way
systems and so forth left turn right
turns things like that where they can be
a real traffic nuisance to people and
Hazard and obviously these were not done
willy-nilly they'd be done where they
are complaints about and the
justifications have actually implemented
because we cannot just implement the
proposal we have to be able to justify
each one are set out and and that and
therefore I think this is not paragraph
It's about helping out on the streets to
make them a safer place for everybody
thank you thank you councilor I've said
counselor wetton
thank you um in introducing
um these these measures the first said
the council is going to need is a lot of
yellow paint because those existing
boxes they're worn out
and it will not be fair upon the
motorists to have poorly
defined Yellow Boxes
um I think it's a little bit cynical to
pick the two Junctions that have been
selected for the
um the start of this two of the busiest
Junctions in Trafford uh one of which I
go a long way around to just to avoid
because it's um
a mix of several different flows of
traffic coming together and I don't see
this measure being a solution to that I
see it being an additional
um an addition of of Chaos and my final
point would be the consultation will be
very important but it will hardly
um be an opportunity for the thousands
of motorists who pour into Trafford uh
from outside from Salford and from the
from the M60 and I I do think that some
um
measures need to be taken in the
consultation to to allow for the fact
that a significant amount of those Road
users Road users will probably not be
um in touch with the consultation
process and so something needs to be
done to to
um to represent them thank you Council
Right Said Vancouver
the paint is worn out then so you can
make us aware of them because part of
the proposals moving forward before the
implemented they will be looked at in
any case in that sense of it but if you
know ones that were not just ones on
those two locations but need any others
but on these other lines please feed
them in so they can teams can actually
be looked at them and I'd simply I do
this where there are lines of any
description that are fading so I do do
that but uh obviously these are chosen
not some because these types because
there are problems uh I'd use myself I'm
not clear councilweight how you actually
avoid them I use both these uh what
particularly the one around the M60 and
I think there's no way uh for north
south you cannot go for that have you
gonna move about from one end the other
to the other and I think I'll lose track
of them out at times I'm sat there
heading north particularly and my lights
are going red and my lights going green
and I can't go anywhere because it's
completely blocked up the traffic
particularly pouring off the motorway
and by the time my uh that traffic has
cleared my lights are back on red again
so it's actually I kind of see that up
secretly it's very frustration for
people so those Junctions were quite
clear then that you'd actually get a
fairer share of of the time around the
lights I think that's that make it
better for all drivers create less uh
frustrations and indeed uh make it uh
it's safe for everyone environment to
use but I think I said again I mean the
consultations have been covered out on
these first two indeed we would not be
offend any of the proposals further down
the line without uh further extensive
consultations with Ward members and so
forth that's clearly set out in the
report so I think it's something that we
have to it's simple as you'll see quite
regularly if you see reports on Facebook
and things like that there's a lot of
frustrations out there that we don't
seem to do anything about the traffic
problems that create in many locations
so I was part was to apply for them to
say that we have to be able to justify
it and and justification is that these
are serious traffic problems that it's
along the 86 one of the busiest routes
in the corner base at the whole of the
connotation I think it's right that we
actually take them seriously I think the
police simply don't have the resources
to actually implement plan uh
enforcement of them and I think that you
know I think the police also need to get
on with some serious works of crime and
so forth and I think it's actually quite
a difficult one to actually deal with
these sort of levels of problems so I
think as a number we do need to take
these seriously I'm quite happy to
actually uh I think to move these
forward and actually start the process
thank you future proposals will not be
implemented uh but without further
consultation reward members thank you
councilor I said Richard you indicated
you wanted to come in at this point yeah
I think just just to add what we'll talk
about here is a transfer of powers from
from the police to um the council we're
not we're not talking about introducing
new yellow bottle Junctions so these are
both both locations are locations that
have got existing yellow box Junctions
where vehicles are in there are subject
to enforcement Power by by the police so
it's not new it's not it's not new
enforcement activity it's the
enforcement activity will be done
through ampr rather than by rather than
by the police of existing yellow
Junctions
correct that there's a six-month grace
period as well after anything's fitted
so yes so so for the first six months
it's a warning unless it's the second uh
offense within that six month period
thank you now there were two more
questions I think councilor new gross
and councilor Blackburn indicated just
I'll take these but just be mindful it
may affect questions later on in the
agenda so uh Council Bradburn first of
all
it's just a point at the two sites
um well known to everybody
um motorists are not given prior warning
that there's going to be a narrowing of
the road and that can cause chaos when
you're coming off the M60 and you're
turning right onto the a56 and then the
road Narrows because of the the
temporary
um cones and it's also the same at White
City Circle went to the match at the
weekend and it was chaos because again
people who don't know the area don't
know that the roads suddenly going to
become narrow so that needs to be you
know thought of thank you okay we might
take that away in because of the time
constraints that we've got but I'll go
to counselor newgrash next thank you
thank you leader
um very very briefly I I uh recognize
the um intention to do it but councilor
adshead was very crucial it's how your
consultation
57 responses and I can remind you of 51
said yes that's 28 people out of a
population of Trafford of 235
000 people is that really a valid
consultation of the public I'm not
certain myself that's question one and
second what do we this isn't going to be
cost neutral we're looking to be able to
sustain and gain revenue what are our
thoughts on Revenue income after cost we
don't know cost yet thank you two
questions okay councilman said just in
terms of the fact last question there I
mean obviously uh in terms of the income
on that one and obviously a lot of this
will go particularly in the early years
it's got towards covering their costs
which is going to be quite extensive
outlays if there are any uh monies left
over at the end of the day in future
years then obviously asset out in the
report that's required to be used in
that we defined areas in terms of uh
helping with things that cycle ways and
traffic sporting buses and all things
like that so it isn't something that we
can actually just use for General days
and the race as a as I think uh there
may be some suggestion out there it's
clearly defined how any extra monies can
actually be and they would certainly be
being friends for those sorts of
evidence it clearly LED it in
legislation as well so there's actually
no way around that one in terms of
consultations uh I mean obviously this
is the first trunch we've acquired two
years beforehand I've been involved over
the years with many types of
consultation and I think can always say
that they're always low levels of
response answers to them sometimes it's
quite surprising I've just just the
other year I was involved in some other
consultation and I was going out to
people selling on the street so please
engage with it but did they no they
wouldn't engage with it and I think at
the end of the day uh the more people
that do engage right it's actually uh it
gives us a fair response but we can only
do so much in that sense of it and
obviously it was put out there and
circulated but obviously a lot of people
come into it maybe from outside of the
borough so I think in that sense of it I
think we have to move forward and
obviously if there are issues and
problems as it develops I think well
genuine ones we can actually look at if
there are particular problems with it
but I think as it falls forward
consultations are always typical deals
and if you've got some suggestions
actually how we deal with future
consultations please do feed them in
we're always happy to look at new
players who do into consultations they
are getting people to engage is
difficult thank you thank you councilor
ad said and finally councilor Welton uh
well the green group very much welcomes
um this I mean it's a great opportunity
to enforce traffic um the traffic rules
and an enforcement of that is a key part
of a successful Vision zero strategy
um I have a question just on 10.4 in the
report
um there's a it's a really interesting
little paragraph there
um which changes the waiting time under
certain certain circumstances at which
point a traffic enforcement officer can
give a ticket which is brilliant because
you know it means that they can in
certain circumstances they pretty much
do it straight away rather than having
to wait five ten minutes by which time
the person who's parked dangerously or
whatever has come back to their their
car I was just wondering will there be
details published about when the one
minute waiting period will as opposed to
five or ten will be applied
um so that people can get familiar with
that and also obviously you know the um
enforcement offices is educated as well
in terms of when they can apply that
power and when it has to be five and ten
minutes thank you thank you councilor I
said briefly uh say Obviously uh this
used to be looked at further to see how
it actually implemented
thank you so I think this is good news
it's um bringing some enforcement into
our hands I think it's going to help
with traffic flow and I think that if we
do get
um some monies from it it'll be
financing
things that will benefit all roads users
not just car drivers so with that I'm
happy to um to say that uh we're
recommended to set up what's on the
recommendation sheet on the front all
those in favor
hi thank you
right next one is the update on response
to scrutiny Gypsy Roma and traveler
Tuscan finish group report and I'm going
to pass over to counselor ad set again
thank you that leader just briefly on on
this one obviously uh we've been
discussing the Egyptian travel Aromas
for the past couple of years there was
an engagement session with councilors
actually many of you in the here may
have actually attended that session the
council chamber and obviously uh since
pandemic I did the full role uh a couple
of years ago and we did see that the
impacts of actually uh some of the
Travelers and the encampments in some
parts of the brother which run off as
can actually have on those little
communities in terms it can be
unexpected we've had a couple of uh
sessions journals somewhere where
Christmas had planned events on a
Saturday morning or the like and that
because of those encampments they
weren't able to that so I think in light
of those sorts of things is actually
right that we actually look at some
temporary software measures now
obviously in the longer term the local
plan will actually deal with that sort
of more permanent type of measures but
however of a an interim would actually
like to pull something that actually has
helped deal with that so it doesn't have
too much impact on communities outside
of those areas it'll also help me help
and supported because obviously proper
cleanup Arrangements will be enough
while flustering and other types of mess
that are left there normally which quite
frankly I don't think some of our staff
should have to deal with some of that
when the mess is left like that in the
local parks and green space it's not
fair unless you have to actually deal
with that so we're putting something
that actually helps deal that actually
more manageable I think certain
something that and does some sort of
members will actually support something
like that because it's actually benefits
also gives the travel somewhere to know
when they're coming into the area they
actually know they can have a defined
Place obviously this is all subject to
consultation with local members and
indeed but we want to have further
discussions with the local with the
communities themselves to actually be
potentially using these facilities with
that I'll leave it at that later
thank you councilor I'd say I'd said are
there any questions from the executive
yeah councilor Williams
um thank you chair and just very briefly
I was hoping to make a a reflection of a
comment rather than ask um a question
because I think this piece of what's
interesting in its Origins
um I think it's really welcome that
members of this scrutiny committee have
formed a task and finish group to look
at a specific item that they've engaged
with Council officers and interested
parties made a series of recommendations
which officers have done been able to
utilize and bringing forward a set of
practical recommendations for
implementation and you know that that's
all been done in a relatively short time
scale and certainly I think that during
my five and a half years on Council this
is amongst some of the best work that
I've seen scrutiny committee Undertake
and um I don't want to speak for anyone
else but I'd very much welcome similar
projects in the future and given that
Council of acting's with us tonight are
just saying closing I hope that you're
able to pass that feedback on to
scrutiny committee members when you next
meet thank you chair
thank you and I completely agree with
all the comments made that um it was an
excellent piece of work and I am aware
that there are other excellent pieces of
work underway or about to begin
um are there any other wider questions
counselor oh sorry Council say to first
and then just a quick just a quick
comment leader thank you I think it's
really
um important that we look at this piece
of work because
um the gypsies traveler and roma
Community are an often overlooked
community and I think it's great that um
Trafford is actually making
um some Headway into support in that um
group when they come through our Bora so
thank you for all the hard work
thank you councilor Slater councilor
Acton
thank you it's not often we get uh
comments like counselor Williams and
it's very pleasing when we do and I will
certainly pass that uh back
um I mean I sat on the task and finish
group and I know that Dan satanators as
well and I thought it was a really good
piece of of work and
um and I think it was required as well
because we we did get quite a lot of
complaints of uh Travelers and gypsies
going on to
um you know the parks and all the other
slices of land in in Trafford and
um and I think
we did make a a series of
recommendations but this was probably
one of the most important one and I
think
um really pleased that the executive uh
took some time to to look uh at the
whole issue
um and to then recommend
a temporary stopping site uh in in the
borough
um it is a really good step forward and
I think
um it's a sensible approach in terms of
uh saying that
this will be a trial basis because I
think we would need to know how how
Travelers react to that I know
consultation has gone on with Travelers
and and gypsies but I think
um you know the proof will be in the
pudding really and I think once we get
that um sorted out and uh and and it's
it's trial then we will be able to make
um further decisions and I think you
know the task and finish group will be
uh you know quite welcoming if if you
wish us to make some further findings
once we move to that stage
oh thank you thank you Council act and
I'm sure we would welcome that in due
course so thank you for that
um councilor Blackburn
thank you leader my one concern about
the Royal Street site is that there
won't be water and this is something
that um when they uh they were the the
visitors were Were King camps near where
I live
um and the other thing I should like to
point out that Boyer streets is
currently used on Match days as an
illegal car park which
um isn't really and there's no real
enforcement and I'm just wondering about
what might happen if they are in Camp
there and the norm the usual
uh supporters
realize what's happening so I just like
just to point out those two things thank
you councilor Blackburn I don't know if
Richard Dawson's councilor I said have
any comments to make just general I mean
obviously uh whenever the app the
encampment's cross the board there are
no water supplies at any of the
locations in in that sense so that in
itself wouldn't be unusual any
particular site but obviously this would
be a hard site rather than a glass site
but obviously uh we've just made note of
your comments there obviously your
second comments in relation to this
being potentially used uh for illegal
match parking obviously we'll take that
way and look at that because we want to
avoid any particular problems on the day
uh each of these things happen that'll
be looked at clearly in advance many
decisions but I think advantages though
they got water from people's homes and
there aren't any houses around boys
Street
thank you and councilor Jerome
thanks leader um I think this was a real
success of the task and Finnish group um
it was it was great to be on and we
worked really well as the team and with
Council Acton's experience and guidance
I think we moved it quite quickly and
got got those changes done I just
wondered um we did have Billy and Lucy
in from the Gypsy traveler or org who
were fantastic and provided great
training for counselors I just wondered
whether that training will continue in
future years for councilors and the
council but also I wonder if if
they will also be consulted and and
other traveling communities on the
changes that we're making so we make
sure that we get them right for not just
residents but for travelers too thank
you thank you on the training point I
certainly hope so um it would be very
good for us or to keep that going
throughout the years um councilor I said
I'll Passover
there certainly will be further uh
consultation and liaison with all
different communities that will be
affected it's certainly a part of it we
couldn't go ahead with sites like this
and obviously did more permanent sites
without engagement with those sort of
communities let's make sure we get them
right absolutely
okay thank you so the recommendations
are as set out in the report all those
in favor
thank you very much some enthusiasm
there
lots of people have had a long Monday by
the sounds of it okay moving on to uh
item 10 which is the business rates
relief Autumn budget measures and
council tax which is still me so this
report sets out that we are going to
follow the guidance the government
guidance for the business rate supports
that was announced in Autumn and we have
got additional funding
um for our council tax support scheme
and that will mean that 3400 recipients
will get up to an extra hundred pounds
in their support over the course of this
year
um and there are no other change
significant changes to the current
council tax support scheme which remains
one of if not the most generous schemes
in Greater Manchester so it's quite a
straightforward report but happy to take
any questions from the executive first
of all
councilor Patel I think it's very
welcome news
um leader I work with a lot of residents
that struggle with their council tax
bills and through home starting in
Trafford the same so all very welcome
absolutely and we've made a conscious
decision year in year out to keep the
scheme as it is and I think this
additional money will be a big help at
this cost of living crisis time any
other questions
okay well the recommendations are as set
out in the report or those in favor
that was a bit better okay
okay next item is the budget monitoring
report period eight um which is still me
so the Alton is estimated is at 4.97
million as at period 8 which is the
Improvement of 1.09 million since period
six
if you strip out the inflation of 5.2
million that we've estimated for the
current year the current performance
versus budget would actually be an
underspend of 229
000 pounds
um there are some key overspends which
include the 656 000 pound overspend in
children's placements and
1.266 million overspend in homeschool
transport I know we're doing some
finance and change work around that area
at the moment the Strategic investment
is um going to be coming in at 1.89
million lower than we forecast at the
budget uh reasons set out in the report
and you will note that there's a 1.93
million pound underspend in the Staffing
budget
in terms of um other aspects of the the
monetary report you'll note that the
2.23 million of investment income from
Surplus cash balances year to date
that's because of the ongoing increases
to the base rate to the bank of England
there's progress on the capital budget
and um I'm happy to take as is Graham
any questions from the executive at this
point
councilor Patel the point you make when
you open about if with strip chat
inflationary costs would be an under
spend is Testament to the tremendous
hard work
um that's gone into producing this
budget I know that the except get it I
know that the labor group get it I hope
that the opposition parties get how
horrendously challenging the financial
situation is that we face
thank you that's a very good point well
made and we are certainly in this
position thanks to the leadership of the
CLT Graham and his team in finance and
you'll recall we are anticipating the
inflation impact very early on in the
year and started making
um preparations for that so thank you
for that councilor Patel any other
questions
okay oh yes councilor wetton
a few mentions this evening about the
cost of living crisis and it's something
that that we'll recognize
um I just wondered if there's a
um a bit more that we could know about
the the impact on the council tax income
um because it's there's just empty boxes
really where I would think we would
normally show a figure uh and I just
wondered how how
is the cost of living crisis showing up
particularly in the council tax receipts
I think that's a very good question I'm
going to see if Graham can give us a
response now or if not we'll come back
to you with more detail Graham
yeah I think
council tax income in Trafford has been
buoyanced it was relatively buoyant
during corvid when we're expecting
um a fall off in collection rate
um similarly in the in the cost of
living
um issues that we've got at the moment I
think what we've seen in a year
our in-ear collection and there is a
table in the report
table two within the report just shows
how we're projecting a surplus on the
overall collection form for Council taxi
Neo just short of half a million pound
um
it's fair to say there's a number of
components within that
um we have seen an increase in
discount single person discounts which
it affected
erode our tax base
to some degree but we've seen conversely
we've seen an increase in collection
particularly some of the historic
collection and and that that we did have
on the books and I think it's it is
something we regularly monitor
um and we've taken a view on that
position for the budget report again but
in the main collection rate and
performance is is still quite healthy in
Trafford as things stand at the moment
thank you thank you kremely it's
obviously an area we will keep an eye
out on as we progress through this
uncertain year as all years are becoming
quite uncertain
um councilman ugrash first thank you
very briefly you highlighted the home to
school transport overrun of 1.266
million
um can I have the reason behind that
please that particular overall I will
give a couple of reasons and then I
would defer to uh to Jill but some of
the reasons include fuel the complexity
of cases the difficulty of getting
Arrangements in place Jill do you want
to add anything else around homeschool
transport I mean essentially we've had
here previously the criteria for home to
school transport we all statutorily
required to prove to provide transport
those children with Education Health and
Care plans and additional needs we have
seen the number of Education Health and
Care plans increase year on year so part
of the finance and change work that's
been referenced is how we can work to
um
intervene earlier to almost stem the
demand in terms of reducing the number
of plans but whilst plans continue to
increase the pressure on the home to
school budget will increase
some of the external factors that
councilor Ross has mentioned cost of
fuel increased runes increased distance
as children need to access education
outside of the borough where they have
Education Health and Care plans
thank you Jill and councilor Jerome
thanks leader on 54 the budget
monitoring report indicates that on the
a56 that
um
Emissions on on pm10s and NO2 are going
up so is the budget failing to tackle
um
clean air on on the a56
okay
um we will have to take that away
actually and just have a look at that in
further detail obviously we are Keen to
to lower emissions
um there are many factors in terms of
looking at lowering emissions hopefully
one of which will be looking at some of
the things that we've already discussed
in the agenda previously but no it
certainly is one of our key monitors
there it will continue to be a monitor
for us and uh yeah we'll take that away
and see if there's any further thought
we can give around Dax it is an
important point that you make
okay well the um recommendations are set
out on the front of the item um all
those in favor
okay
right so um the next item is item 12
which is the real living wage
accreditation which again Falls to me
this is a very good news story for the
borough we're now at a point where we're
going to apply for the real living wage
accreditation this will mean that 320
staff across the council in schools who
are on the lowest pay scales will
receive additional payments at a time
they face a cost of living crisis as we
have already referenced in previous
reports
um it means that we will join five of
our local authorities in Greater
Manchester as well as 55 organizations
within the borough to have real living
wage accreditation I think this is
really good news this has been quite a
long journey to get to this point and it
would be remiss of me not to pay tribute
to the work of my predecessor councilor
Western as he was very passionate about
mcgetigans to this stage it's only a
shame that he missed out on presenting
this himself but um no I think this is a
good news or to uh to be thankful for
are there any questions or comments from
the executive
let's cancel this later
it's really really impressive that we've
got to this in this really bad situation
financially and I think that you know
it's it's really good that we're looking
after our staff that our staff are
worthy of being paid properly I just
think that it's amazing and I'm just so
proud that we've been able to achieve
this as a Borough and I just hope that
other um businesses within the borough
work to that as well I know that you
said that there was quite a few but I
think it'd be really good if we can
become a borough of um
that you know is a living wage Borough I
think it'd be brilliant so thank you for
all the hard work everybody's done and I
think it's fantastic for our staff
completely green it's also obviously an
aspiration for greater Manchester as
well so I'm glad that we're playing our
part in Trafford any other questions
from exec members
any wider questions
okay well the recommendations are I set
out on the front of the report all those
in favor
marvelous thank you the next item is
agenda item 13 which is the parks tennis
Improvement project so councilor Harding
thank you leader
um I feel like I've um made several
points due to the questions that were
asked earlier on in the meeting but I
bring this report and as I bring this
report I would like the executive and
The Wider executive to focus on the
words investment and sustainability
I'm sure that many of you will have
visited your local park in your ward and
you may have some comments about the
condition and the state of some of the
tennis courts in those Parks
um some of them are looking rather tired
neglected and definitely uninviting and
they're also being used for purposes
other than tennis really and the aim of
having tennis courts is that they are
going to be used for the purposes of
tennis
um we are looking in next month's
executive to bring forward the Trafford
moving strategy and the aim is to make
sure that as many people across Trafford
can be active and keep themselves well
to to work towards our corporate
priority of reducing Health inequalities
so people stay active and well
um
at 1.3 this gives a little bit of
background and what this paper is
seeking to approve and this is about
securing investment to make our courts
more sustainable and we have a future
sustainable model around operations and
maintenance and making tennis accessible
for all information that there are 34
courts across 12 sites and on a desktop
exercise there the courts are in varying
states of disrepair with only two of
them actually listed as good
the
there's been limited investment over the
years of this past decade and just to to
refer to what councilor Patel said
really these are challenging and
difficult times and local government has
lost 60 pence in every pound so you know
we've had to make tough decisions over
the years really
so we are left with options about how we
make tennis accessible and the Court's
sustainable we could do nothing and I
think we all know if we do nothing where
that is going to lead us
we could look at option two which is the
council maintains and improves the
current Network at its own cost I think
as we've all discussed the current
budget challenges it doesn't leave us
with a long-term option or we seek this
investment from the LTA which allows us
to implement a sustainable operating
model there are conditions obviously
around the access gates and the charging
and an operator
so
um if we proceed and the executive agree
with this report tonight we will
obviously open up to further engagement
With Friends of Park groups and I want
to put on public record my thanks to the
Friends of Park groups for the brilliant
work that they do but the fact is they
cannot possibly sustain all the hard
work it takes to maintain all of the
parks they are volunteers at the end of
the day
so we are we would look to introduce the
charge but that would be um scalable
across the parks and again I'm Keen I'm
absolutely Keen to make sure that we
make tennis accessible to all and as
I've previously stated there will be
some free tennis sessions for people too
we do need a specialist operator for us
to make sure that we can promote and
market and communicate what a good
tennis offer looks like and I don't know
whether you've had an opportunity to
look at the LTA website they do have a
mission statement which is about making
sure that tennis is accessible to all
I'm very happy to work with friends of
and other community groups to visit some
of the parks across Manchester that have
already invested in this model I think
that would be you know a good idea for
us to have a look at what works and what
we could possibly have here in Trafford
so that offer is open from me
so that said you've seen the report in
front of you there would be next steps
we'd look to finalize what the next what
the LTA investment would be we would
look to engage wider not just friends of
groups we want to engage with the wider
public
um we want to re-engage groups we'd look
to procure an operator but there's more
for us to do really so the report is in
front of you and I asked the exec to
consider thank you thank you councilor
Harding and thank you for your answers
at the start of this meeting which I
thought were very comprehensive are
there any questions uh councilor Slater
want to roll out
and thank you for the paper councilor
Harding and staff who supported you to
put it together I think just I think I'm
quite shocked when I look at you know
the the graph there how poor some of our
provision is in some areas of the Bora
and if we want to Future proof our Parks
we have to have
um equipment and areas that are you know
that are of a good standards so you know
I welcome what you've brought to us
today and I look forward to the wider
consultation and I think that you know
the if we don't improve the parks in
this sort of way we are going to end up
with antisocial behavior in those areas
that will just decimate our park so
thank you thank you councilor Slater and
councilor Patel
I think a councilor Harding's offer of
um a sort of visit and look at other
areas where this model has operated very
successfully our neighbors in Manchester
have operated it for some years
um far from limiting access to tennis
the story in Manchester is that it's
actually opened up tennis to more people
from more different from lots of
different backgrounds and giving people
a chance who've never played tennis to
play tennis
so without this funded from the lawn
tennis Association I really fear that
that we will simply lose tennis courts
in Trafford as they fall further into
disrepair it's a challenging decision
but it's a positive option we've been
presenting with here
thank you councilor Patel are there any
other questions uh councilor Jerome
thank you leader
um we have had quite a bit of feedback
from
um Parks such as Stanford Park and John
Lee Park and they tell us that their
free courts are used regularly by by
residence and and they enjoy them
greatly and they seem to feed back to us
that this very much feels like a
privatization of the courts
um which is quite worrying and and that
kind of leads me on to the consultation
we're told in in the report the that the
ltls the LTA scheme will be mapped out
in Spring 2023 which is quite soon so um
when would the consultation be how long
will it go on for and how are you going
to reach the those ad hoc tennis players
that kind of that will be dis and could
possibly be disenfranchised by by what's
going on and also there was one
criticism that they brought forward to
us that
um that they have emailed the council to
get some kind of some of their questions
answered but emails just haven't been
replied to so that that's been quite
annoying for the mod I just wanted you
could give some reassurance on that too
thank you Council
to try and find out why
he responded to and get some responses
in relation to you mentioned that you'd
had feedback I think it's always useful
for counselors would to feed some of
that back to the executive and you
mentioned about further engagement I
would look toward counselors to help
with some of that engagement you're part
of your community you're rooted in your
community you have access to some of
those groups that may be officers of the
council don't have so I would definitely
be seeking you to be part of the
engagement process I do challenge the
privatization when I look and think
about it's actually the LTA which are
very community-minded Community spirited
and they are looking to make tennis
accessible to war and I would beg the
question to you councilor Jerome if we
do nothing what are we going to be left
within the long run so I take the points
and I will get back to you in relation
to the emails but actually I would hope
to work with Ward counselors to try and
make this a positive thing for members
of the community to access sport for all
thank you councilor Harding I'm going to
go to counselor for us now
oh sorry councilor Jeremy you threw a
lot of information at me at one point so
I probably didn't get all of that I can
absolutely find out the process of the
consultation I would want it to be as
transparent and accessible as possible
so I'm not hiding anything if I didn't
answer it I just missed that point so
thank you thank you counselor for us
thank you leader so the lawn tennis
Grant is genuinely really good news I
was quite excited to see about this
investment particularly as there's some
dilapidated courts not very far from me
but there's always strings attached and
my question really is why those strings
are entangled around the courts that are
listed as good condition color coded in
green so for example the volunteers at
Pickering Lodge are quite concerned that
the restricting of the access they tell
me and I quote uh Pickering Lodge is
about someone just having the
opportunity to pop down at any time for
a quick game unscheduled children
sometimes use them to learn to ride
their bikes and the local groups there
don't feel that's a problem so the word
of segregation that was mentioned
earlier to keep this strictly for tennis
and to limit the access with the gates
for those that don't need the lawn
tennis Association Grant color-coded in
green seems a little bit of overreach
thank you
thank you councilor Harding thank you
councilor frass just to remind you they
are tennis courts they're not cycle
paths so there are plenty of other paths
in parks where children can safely learn
to ride their bike so I do just want to
remind you they are actually Tennis
Courts Reference has been made about
people using the courts that is
absolutely brilliant we want as many
people to use the courts as possible
they're good now they might not be good
in the long term if we don't develop
some sustainable funding in a
maintenance program so the AVS that we
make them good for the long term and I
refer again they are I want everybody to
be able to pop down to their local
tennis court and to make sure they can
be fit active well and be involved in a
sport that isn't Elite it's seen as
something that everybody can enjoy so
thank you
um councilor butt
thank you chair uh actually welcome uh
any kind of investment and sustainable
strategy in order to support the tennis
so I did but there's some things I just
want to ask as well and we're assuming
there is a pent-up demand for tennis
that will override the charges uh I mean
how sound are the LTA projections and
Trafford tennis courts are becoming
self-sustaining and self-financing after
introducing the charges and how robust
is the lta's demand data is also the the
consultation should take place to
corroborate and endorse the LTA data
before any decision is made on this
option which is option three we've seen
over here uh and the 4.1 which uh
indicates that the LTA costs 125 000
which includes access gates for the uh
the courts uh but I think the the
council later on in that report says
it's for repairs 125 pound for repairs
uh according to the LTA tech service I'm
just wondering whether the council is
saying that it's 125 000 for the repairs
or what the Delta said is repairs and
the gates
okay Council Harding
um thank you councilor but again lots of
information uh lots of points that
you've raised with me I think in
relation to the data of the LTA there's
no issue with us going back to the LTA
but let us remember they are the
specialists in this area and they will
have done lots of modeling and data
around tennis and making it more
accessible but if you want to put
forward a form of words to me that I can
make sure we can put that to the LTA but
that will also form part of the ongoing
consultation if Ward councilors and
Resident groups and park groups have
further questions that they want
answering that forms part of the further
consultation so do please feel free to
message me any questions you have about
challenging the robustness of the data
in relation to the money and I'm going
to look to Richard I my understanding is
um that the courts need a sinking fund
of 1 200 per year to ensure that they
are the general and scheduled
maintenance can take place my
understanding is as part of the
conditions the Council would maintain
Gates
okay thank you very much for that nod
there Richard
um right the recommendations are a set
out on the front of the report all those
in favor
thank you very much now on to agenda
item 14 which is fair price for care and
councilor Karina Carter
thank you leader
um I'm delighted to bring this report to
you this evening and as colleagues are
aware we are required by a law to
consult on the fair price for care with
our providers and this report details
their responses there's lots of good
news in this report
um like the fact 100 of our home care
providers are now paying the real living
wage following on from Leader's earlier
report to their Care staff and that is
up from 70 less last January
21 out of 32 Care Homes are also paying
real living wage which is a clear
Improvement
as last year there was only a third of
Nursing and Residential Care Homes
paying it
we continue to monitor the program
progress of the ethical care Charter and
tonight I am seeking approval for the
following inflationary uplifts
we're planning on giving 9.1 percent for
Residential Care Homes 8.7 for Home Care
staff both uplifts are close to
inflation and will hopefully be welcomed
by the sector so I recommend these
proposals for your approval thank you
thank you councilor Carter are there any
questions from the executive
any wider questions councilor whetton
not a question just a comment very much
uh welcoming the reporters uh council
card has said a lot a lot of good news
in there
um and quite a an example of a
trickle-down of improvements for the
various
um levels of people within within the
industry so
um it's very very pleasing to see it's
impressive to see
um percentages like that actually being
awarded
um and um
but well just very pleased to see all of
the data that's in there
thank you councilor Watson I completely
agree it is very this is a good news
item and uh largely down to the work of
council Carter and indeed Diane Eaton
and we must keep noting and thanking
Diane whilst we still have her in the
room so yeah thank you very much
um the recommendations are set out this
is in the paper all those in favor
thank you okay the next item is uh item
15 which is the greater Manchester
minimum licensing standards for taxi and
private hire stage two vehicles in
councilor rights absence councilor ad
set is going to present this report
thank you leader yes sir just uh I'll
just look at this quickly uh as you will
be aware of uh the reasons for the
report is actually set out that the
clean air fund itself hasn't the clean
taxi fund has not been opened so the
grants have not really been taken up and
been available for the Hackney carriage
and private hired drivers so I think in
that sense what the report is doing is
actually asking for the work around this
to be delayed and that is set out in the
summary at the front of the page there
that's our page and obviously in that
sense it puts it back to a couple of
years and moving forward on that one so
I think this is sensible straightforward
and simple updation of the existing
position so I think uh as I'm not
completely feeling of all aspects of it
I'll leave it there and actually ask for
any questions thank you councilman said
that was a very good summary any
questions from the executive
any wider questions
quick question do do we know the um
percentage impact of out of borough cars
that are operating in uh under as
private higher Anders hackneys uh in in
Trafford now and how do we feel about
the fact that we haven't got so much
control over those cars at all okay I'll
go to Richard
I don't have an answer in terms of the
number of
um out of borough licensed taxes I'm not
sure that we can necessarily get that
information because we don't have to
report to us or or tell us and I think
it's fair to say we're very disappointed
that we don't have the powers to prevent
those who are licensed out of borrow
from operating within greater Manchester
that was part of our original ambition
around the MLS
um but we don't have the powers to do
that that will require a national policy
change but um we certainly don't like it
we're not happy about it and we'd rather
that they weren't operating
um within greater Manchester and
certainly within Trafford
foreign
thank you um could I ask you to get you
to be there with regard to the swivel
seats in the Hackney
Castle
um because it's it it's noted that the
consultation response was was quite low
these swivel seats are really handy for
for disabled people so that they can
they they come out they can go on and
then they swing around
um you know you know for those who
aren't as mobile
um obviously they're not they're not
used in in you know the the private hire
but you know with the black cabs they
are and I think it's it is something
because we have got um you know an aging
population in Trafford and not everybody
can afford to use a taxi but when they
do it would be helpful for them to you
know to have something like that
thank you
okay
an odd there so thank you very much for
that counselor Blackburn okay the
recommendations are a set out on the
front of the item um all those in favor
technology wonderful and agenda item 16
is the corporate equality strategy
progress update countless later thank
you leader and today's report is our
six-month review of the equality
strategy and the work that we've been
doing and I think you'll all be aware
that there this was originally a joint
um strategy between Trafford Council and
ccg however from the 1st of July 2022
the ccg no longer exists and um we have
now um greater Manchester integrated
care service and and we are going to be
working with them
um in the same way that we're working
with the ccg and they are adapting and
the the equality strategy alongside us
and we're making really good Pro
progress and we are meeting our public
equality objectives and and I just
thought I'd give a few um updates of
where we where we're at about and our
equality training and we have
2181 staffs who had completed the and
quality essentially the training and now
we've had a further 205 added to that
from July and 2022 so I think it's
really important that you know that
we're supporting our staff to be able to
take time away to do that training and
also for us as elected councilors to do
that as well
um health and well-being and equality
diversity inclusive staff development
program is underway which includes deaf
awareness courses menopause support
Financial well-being domestic abuse
awareness we are working in partnership
with great with greater Sports on a home
office funded project in Old Trafford
and Stratford to improve safety for
women and girls and we're going to be
encouraging enable and enabling safe
activity around Old Trafford football
ground and also around the cricket
stadium
uh Public Health are delivering focused
stop smoking work and I think that those
that were at Health scrutiny this week
will have heard some of the really good
um work that we've progressed there
we're working with trading standards
also to to reduce the prevalence of Vape
Vapes that have been sold to our young
residents and we're working with schools
to offer stop stop smoking education
within the schools School setting the
community safety team has funded School
workshops on hate crime and working on
projects in schools that are aimed at
tackling racism and a new prevent
coordinator has been appointed and has
started with the council this January
in August this last year the voice of
BME celebrated 15 years of serving
diverse communities in Trafford and many
councils were invited to their um Awards
presentation the leader of the council
Andrew Weston at the time before um well
I should say Andrew Western MP now
shouldn't I
um he accepted an award for um the
recognition that the council has
contributed over the last few years and
in in the uh volunteering Community
section with the voice of BME and also
we have a principal Community cohesion
and equality officers who were also
present at the awards in October and the
work that they've been they have been
doing was also noted by um the voice of
BME for um for their well well for their
good works and Iowa also attended the
Black History Month event on the 20th of
October which focused on mental health
and our black and Asian and Caribbean
and South Asian men at the Limelight and
hopefully some of you will have been
able to have a look at the outcomes from
that on the 3rd of October last year of
Citizen survey uh was was uh started
about how we move away from using Bain
in Trafford and how we're looking at the
new terminology around our black and
Asian ethnic minority and Workforce and
residents so we will have some further
information on that for exec in to uh in
March so all's going really well with
the um with the strategy really pleased
that we are moving forward with the hard
work that
um we knew that we would have to do in
Trafford since we didn't have one until
a couple of years ago so any questions
I'm happy to take those and if I can't
get answers for you today I'll make sure
that you get them thank you thank you
councilor Slater I mean the I thought it
was an excellent report
um it's clear that a lot of work has
taken place in this area and there was a
lot of valuable information in here as
well so you know I I learned a lot
through reading reading it recently are
there any other questions or comments
from the executive councilor Patel thank
you you just Echo it's a really
interesting and positive report the the
point the interesting point for me as
well is um
the census update uh which I haven't
accessed personally yet for Trafford but
I'm really looking forward to having a
look at it the headlines there show that
Trafford is is a change place from the
last census so it's perhaps something
for all Ward members to have a look at
I think that's a very good point
councilor Patel and the census maps are
out there and they make a fascinating
read for 2021 in the picture of Trafford
and I know that we are doing some work
as a council so we'll be sharing that
information in in due course are there
any other questions or comments
okay well the recommendations are as set
out on the front of the report or those
in favor
thank you very much so I have not been
notified of any urgent business so I'm
going to move on to item 18 which is the
exclusion resolution which uh just like
my predecessor I will now try and read
out so the motion is that the public be
excluded from this meeting during
consideration of the remaining items on
the agenda because of the likelihood of
disclosure of exempt information which
falls into one or more descriptive
category or categories of the Local
Government Act 1972 schedule 12a as
amended by the local government access
to information variation order 2006 and
specified on the agenda item or reports
relating to each such item respectively
almost did that perfectly not quite our
work on that
um are the cameras now off Alex
okay